cbs news medical contributor dr david
agus is here with
more david let me start with actually
something positive and jeff said this
just a couple minutes ago the new daily
case count down 64
from that all-time high set back on
january 2nd
why are we seeing this drop now well we
saw a significant increase because over
the holidays we let our guard down and
we got together and that dramatic
increase happened over the first several
weeks of january
now it's going down because of several
reasons we're more compliant we're
wearing masks which is the good thing
because of the cold weather people
aren't going out for testing
and there is less testing now right a
lot of resources went from testing to
giving vaccines
and obviously with less testing you're
going to have less positive cases
dr want to ask you about a couple new
studies obviously our knowledge of the
vaccine
is going up uh new data from israel is
out regarding the effectiveness of a
one-shot
vaccine there's also a new study from
the uk that examined the timing
between doses what have we learned from
those studies
so they're both optimistic the the one
shot in israel showed that
about 85 percent of people didn't have
symptoms when they got one shot
and that was that kind of 28 days at a
month the problem is is that we need
those two shots in order to get a high
enough level of immunity to be lasting
for a long time
and to fight against the variants that
are rising across the globe
in the uk it was a very interesting
study as they looked at instead of
giving it three weeks they gave it at
several months later
and they showed no decrement at all in
fact slightly higher immune response
when you waited a little bit longer so
when the trials were designed
three four weeks was the minimum and
what we know now is that if you wait
several weeks it's okay
so the numbers are going up vaccinations
went from 19 million
to about a month ago to 60 million now
we learned yesterday of four new federal
vaccine sites will have the
that will have the ability to vaccinate
some 12 000 people a day
president biden suggesting we'll have
enough supply for all americans by
august so
are we on track for that
you know we had a little decrement this
week and then obviously vaccines weren't
shipped but
manufacturing is going up we hopefully
have two new vaccines
approved with emergencies authorization
over the next weeks which is jansen and
johnson and shortly thereafter hopefully
astrazeneca so yeah i think by the end
of the summer we could have
heard immunity in the country it's
possible but we have to execute we're up
to
1.7 million doses or so a day take out
the snow delay
and i think that's getting better it
needs to be a lot better
we have to stop saving doses in the
states four second doses and use every
dose we have now
because the federal government has
committed to three weeks in advance
telling states exactly what they're
going to get
so they don't have to save doses for the
future yes
so many folks signing up and still no
answer
from those vaccine sites dr david agus
looking for for help here thank you so
much